for the red burritos 511 Jack Papa
Rattlers 506 Blake Norton for the
Rattlers Flex 500 Jeremy Bramley
also for the red burritos make it a
debut Maddie McDonald
so I'm Maddie McDonald
um I'm 18 years old I've been competing
for seven years and
um Nika has been really fun especially
since he's been my coach so cool I don't
know I think that maybe makes it less
fun because I'm the ghost yeah but it's
nice of you to say that yeah
and then uh anyway my name is Mike
McDonald
uh I've been coaching this team or we
started this team up in
2017 MacDonald
[Applause]
the start of the race is always the like
scariest part and I'm like
I always have the most like nerves built
up just like standing there like just
sitting there waiting for like the
countdown is the scariest part but like
once you get going and everyone's like
cheering you on it's like super fun and
I really like the environment just like
racing with all these kids and just
lines of people cheering you on it's
like taught me how to like be
disciplined because I would go on I
would try to get like three rides in
every week just to keep myself healthy
and like just to make me feel good and
um I don't know I just mountain biking
to me is a way to like get away from
problems so you can just go out in
nature and you're by yourself and you
can push yourself like how hard you want
and um it made me more confident like
finding this thing that I'm like
that I have a talent for so I don't know
I've definitely learned a lot and I
really like just like
going on a ride for fun it makes me like
feel good well we've had races here
since 2019 but I think my favorite thing
about competing is just like being an
environment with a bunch of
kids like my age who also
um are involved and like like mountain
biking because like with my normal like
with my other group of friends they
don't really understand it so if these
people it's like oh we can all share the
same common interests so it's like super
fun
and like as far as competing I think I
like the adrenaline and like the rush I
get from like all my team like
supporting me and like cheering me on
and it like helps me like go faster and
like it just like uplifts me and makes
me feel good and I like doing the same
to them when they're racing so I think
that's my favorite part is like just
cheering everyone on and supporting each
other it's super fun
some kids take it really seriously some
kids just want to come and hang out with
the team and that's fine they don't want
to race I mean we try and make it fun we
have uh games at the park we um we play
bike soccer with a big huge um yoga ball
and we there's been so many kids that
just they start off kind of into it and
they get they just find something a
lower gear and just they take off and
see some of the strides that they make
throughout the throughout the year is
amazing
um I always tell them at the first year
I'm like whether you guys left were you
like mountain biking or something else
just find something
to push yourself in this was our team
got first place
um overall this was the this year's
series
and then this was
um the 2022 series our team also got
first place
and this was 2021.
and then here's yours oh yeah and then
this was this is my plaque for varsity
girls
um since I was the 2023 Series champion
foreign